can't get over here we've got some
criminals to catch on my way time to
catch some criminals okay so I'm not
really David Hasselhoff and this isn't
actually an invincible but sassy Pontiac
Trans Am and well the tesla model s p90d
can't quite think for itself it does now
come with a new kind of self-driving
feature called summit using the key a
smartphone or an Apple watch you can
make your Tesla roll forward and
backward from outside the car that's
handy for getting into and out of space
is so tight you can't open the door more
than a few inches now some it may not be
as cool as Tesla's autopilot function
which lets the car steer for itself
anywhere it can see lane lines but it's
an equally important part of CEO Elon
Musk vision for a world of self-driving
cars
that's because autonomous driving will
change a lot more than what we do when
we're behind the wheel
today with summon you don't have to walk
to your garage that's pretty cool in
just two years Elon promises you'll be
able to call up your Tesla from just
about anywhere even across the country
Michael Knight never had it so good
summon may not be much for now but it's
one more tool we'll need in a world in
which humans no longer drive KITT play
me my theme song hi Siri play me some
Edie's music to drive off to